okay you know it can be a challenge to
find a place to Showcase your Artistry a
non-profit Gallery is trying to fill the
void Lauren negrady looks at how city of
the world gives aspiring creators a
chance to Showcase their skills
the exhibit here at North Las Vegas city
hall is just one of several programs
that city of the world offers I struggle
with expressing myself in words if I
don't plan it out beforehand and drawing
is kind of like the only way I have to
express myself Margarita Moreno is a
10th grader at Founders Classical
Academy of Las Vegas her art is one of
many on display so I actually struggle
with anxiety and a lot of the things
they tell me to do is to breathe and
then and then calm down and when I think
of calm I usually think of water in May
Moreno will have her own wall and art
for sale at city of the world Art
Gallery in Meadows Mall the gallery gets
a small portion of proceeds its
executive director and teacher Roz
Knight says they educate and boost local
artists I believe that the Arts Are the
Healer the educator and The Equalizer in
the whole world they host workshops for
all ages and even offer free Art in the
Park and arts to go programs we're in
need of everything okay we're poor kids
and teachers can display Student Art for
free while artists rent a wall and musk
Gallery sit seven hours a month since
the gallery can't afford to hire staff
artists are able to run their own
workshops and sell at Community
galleries like this one the breathe
exhibit runs through the end of March in
North Las Vegas Laura negretti 8 News
Now
city of the world Art Gallery meanwhile
is ramping up its spring and summer
calendar we have details at 8newsnow.com
Heather